so I think one of our big crises here is
how do we move past a market model or a
model of technology innovation and
distribution that is based purely on
profit access the one that is about
innovation some competition some profit
but also about moral ethical just
behavior about making the connections
about seeing the other not as our
competitor always sometimes but not
always seeing the other as a partner
right worthy of just treatment I think
that's that's interesting even in a
market sense because people tend to
think of global markets as largely and
necessarily sites of competition
they can also be sites of sharing they
can also be sites of exchange exchange
doesn't mean always the maximization of
profit we invented that we can mess with
it position a stake that is not just
profit driven right I mean health should
be delivered for help health should be
delivered for money think about what we
do we have as a per for profit so
hospitals schools and prisons how can
those things be for profit or military
well the whole idea of a prison for
profit the idea that how do you make pop
out of prison you have more people in
prison that's gonna drive a system and
incarcerate more people a healthcare
system where profit is the I'm not
saying you shouldn't do research and
make money off of new drugs and charge
people for access to health care but the
goal should be to make people health
they make their lives better rather than
to make extra money I think doctors
should be paid well I think teachers
should be paid well how do you develop
radically unequal systems you do it by
other people you do it by making someone
less than you do by having a system
whether the haves and the have-nots and
the only way we as humans can can live
with that is if we differentiate
ourselves thinking that the others that
have less have less because that worth
less
and our political and historical
economic structures over the last you
know couple millennia clearly show that
this is a pattern in process especially
over the last 500 300 years you look at
sort of older men in the United States
you want the top indicator of longevity
and happiness is it's not wealth it's
not even what they did as a job in their
life it might not even be whether or not
they had a family it's how many
individuals late in life they identify
as friends
it's how robust their social network yes
yeah someone's opinion me contradict
yours what is my friend Alan it's all
about your perspective who are we and
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on were on-site
at the American Anthropological
Association annual meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia in Canada for our
second partnership with them we are now
going to be speaking with for our second
time on the show dr. Augustine Fuentes
hey thanks I'm really happy to be here
I'm so pumped for this conversation
we've had a year of going off and
augmenting our worldviews and now coming
back and I'm I want to start with this
okay are we really all one yeah yes
right so this is one of those big
questions that I don't think we think
about enough right what do we mean by
that oh we all one there's a lot of
people say oh there's all this big
connection what have you and just let it
float out there so the floating out
there that being connected that's
actually really important but let me
come back to that why don't we just ask
the biological question are we all one
yep we are all human beings share 99
99.9% of all their DNA so everything
when you spin the tube and set it off to
23andme and they tell you your
background that's point zero one percent
of your DNA that varies everything else
you share in common
everyone else on the planet and so this
idea that biologically humans look a
little different you know height weight
skin color hair type
that's really really minor we are one
species we're not only one species but
all 7.5 billion humans on the planet or
more biologically similar to one another
then our white-tailed deer in North
Carolina and white-tailed deer Nome in
Nebraska humans are one what does this
mean right well it doesn't mean we don't
vary a lot that's not a lot of
biological diversity it doesn't mean
that we as a species are really tightly
knit and yet we're spread all over the
planet doing all sorts of incredible
things so it's amazing how what are in
what ways are we one beyond just the
biology and how we live with each other
and how we deal with the world I think
it's a good question and it's worth
reminding ourselves that we are one is
it then that the most upstream issue
that our society faces that we forget
that we're all one that we experience
feelings of separation rather than
interconnectedness so on two levels
that's exactly a huge problem one level
is incredible inequality right today on
the planet we have an inequality that
humans have never experienced it's
extreme right was the latest date I saw
there are three men three guys in the
United States who own 47% of the wealth
that that's a problem right so there is
a reality of inequality material social
structural inequality let's put that
aside for a moment because that's
historical political economic the thing
about isolation or feeling of separation
this sort of psychological sense that
you're alone right that's really
dangerous because what we are as
primates and as humans are social beings
and the ability to be one another with
one another is sort of what that's what
we do that's what made us human in many
ways so so this this contemporary
landscape where people feel isolated
alone without connections without
friends isolate from their family that's
really serious and we don't pay enough
attention to that
because that is how you mess up a human
any project right how do you created
crazy primate isolate them have you
created crazy human isolate them and we
are doing a good job of that in our
contemporary society of making people
feel isolated that's dangerous
whoa yeah so the more that we feel
separated the more we see the downstream
issues of mental health yeah and so
think about this and this is not to say
that people aren't different and have
different kinds of social relationships
we deal we vary a lot there's a lot of
ways in which we interact more
introverts extroverts all of that but
it's but it's it's what you just pointed
out this idea of of increasing sense of
not belonging of not connecting with
others and we see a lot of those issues
here in this country today and
downstream it's not just mental illness
right but it's it's it's sort of a loss
of the connection to other humans it
yeah and once you lose that connection
really really bad things can happen and
and we need to spend a lot more time
thinking about that yeah let's also
touch on the loss of feelings of
connection to other humans and also the
loss of the connection to the just
complete interconnectedness of reality
in general because the breath that I
breathe in comes from phytoplankton and
trees hey and the bite of the Apple that
I take comes from the power of the Sun
there's no separation and that that
being there from in the first days of
the child being a passed on through that
and indigeneity actually has a good
amount of these principles that are
rooted yeah please but modernity in many
ways does it's not and so there being
some sort of an interesting Union
potentially of these two so I mean yeah
so here's the thing we have to be very
careful about thinking oh there's some
better way to be human right the way
we're being human is the way we are
human right there are better ways we can
do it but we can always look to the past
or other societies all right one thing
we have to do is recognize what you just
said
right the entire ecosystem I mean the
planetary ecosystem is a system it's
interconnected and it's constantly
cycling through right so I think we have
to remember as humans we often forget
that we are just we're part of the
system you know no matter how great we
think we are no matter how powerful we
think we are we're going to die and
degrade but that death and degradation
is part of the biological processes the
systemic movement of things through
other things right you talked about
eating the Apple right just think of
what's in that Apple and where it came
from and the tree and the growth and
coming through the body and going out of
our body you can get caught up into sort
of the incredible nough Sufis and I
think it's worth doing that every now
and then but then also what's for me
really important is to recognize that
we're part of ecosystem and recognize
our moral and ethical obligations to the
rest of the ecosystem right once we
recognize we're part of it we can't go
around destroying or screwing over the
rest of it it doesn't work that way
when you have a system by definition the
system is working together connecting
moving through one another throw a
wrench in that trash one part of the
system and use a cascade effect across
the board and that's what we're seeing
today I mean humans the hubris of one
species exactly we're really good at
messing with the world to work better
for us right and that's worked for us
for a long time and it still is the
problem is we're messing with the world
at a rate and an intensity and with a
frequency empower that we never
experienced before
there are 7.5 billion human beings on
the planet all messing with stuff
there's some yes there's some
interesting aspects to this where you
can view other species like chickens
pigs and cows that we've populated on
the planet right well that big hockey
stick and then we're inflicting death
upon their consciousness for food when
now in the next couple of decades we
hope to grow clean meat and bio reactors
which is a very interesting solution
indistinguishable which is very
interesting and then you have other
things like
you talk about the interconnectedness of
tinkering all eight or so billion of us
well we also dig up a lot of things from
the ground energy phosphate fuels right
but um also all of the different
materials that go into these incredible
devices that yeah yeah that we've been
assemble and so this is again and this
is one of the really the things that
just hits us upside the head in its
complexity because I write it said right
7.5 billion 8 billion humans all taking
stuff doing stuff but we're not all
doing it equally right some were doing
it a lot more than others so the digging
of stuff up right so here in the United
States we dig up stuff bring it to us
and use it and exploit it in ways that
are much more intensive than many other
people around the world so that's
interesting so there's an inequality and
in who's consuming and how they're
consuming and where they're getting that
consumption from so it's not like all
humans are doing the same kind of
trashing of the landscape this is the
classical power law so you have a 5% of
the population in the u.s. consuming 25%
of the global energy and stuff like this
it had its or 17% of the population when
you buy that cup of coffee 50% of the
planet makes less than that cup of
coffee cost per day yeah that kind of
stuff back to the we are all one we've
got to remember that if if we are all
connected and what we do is the species
does work together and socially
collaborating whatever we put ourselves
in a position that really challenges our
capacity to get along so I think this
inequalities which we started with that
really undergirds a lot of the trauma
that we are going through and that we're
delivering to the earth yeah this is
interesting so this root word inequality
I like this so if we stay with this
notion of how could it be that you know
three people have 47 percent of the
wealth use 50 percent of all new wealth
or more goes to just that one percent of
people you know how dude as you make
these beautiful emerging markets of
technology that are coming and
democratizing things
anything's better let's type of stuff
how do you make it so that
they're driven by ethics philosophy
morals how do we distribute the fruits
of our across the world these types of
things and also how do we view and this
is an interesting question for you how
do we view this quote/unquote other
right that's actually our cell right
right right right
so how I mean that there's so much right
there but that there are two things
maybe three things that jump out at me
the first one is the first part of your
question you know we have this
incredible democratizing technologies
right this incredible ability to
disseminate power knowledge access but
we're not doing it extremely well right
why not part of it is and this is a bias
that I have but I think I think it is
borne out by data part of it is we're
committed to this notion of a reality of
a neoliberal capitalist system that is
the idea that profit has to drive that
without a profitable capitalist
competitive market we don't have
innovation we don't have this incredible
like discovery and creativity that's not
true we don't only need competitive
markets to deliver goods to ratchet up
technologies to make life livable we
invented that it's not in nature doesn't
mean it's wrong it just means it's not
the only way to do things
we know this so I think one of our big
crises here is how do we move past a
market model or model of technology
innovation and distribution that is
based purely on profit access to one
that is about innovation some
competition some profit but also about
moral ethical just behavior about making
the connections about seeing the other
not as our competitor always sometimes
but not always seeing the other as
apartment right worthy of just treatment
I think that's that's interesting even
in a market sense because people tend to
think of global markets as largely and
necessarily sites of competition they
can also be sites of sharing
they can also be sites of exchange
exchange doesn't mean always the
maximization of profit we invented that
we can mess with it what did we do in
the early days of creating and tinkering
there was no intellectual property and
wanting to if I wanted to bring it to
other people there's almost more about
being and playing and in experiencing
together and maybe the this is probably
also something really important to talk
to you about just that these notions of
of of inclusive fitness were much
stronger when I I would be with you in
our in our tribe and I would never tell
you something to harm you there was no
point that's shooting yourself in the
foot and then what why why now as if it
feels like as we've globalized to this
degree people tell me things and you can
see it from the you know big food big
pharma big gov politics it just doesn't
seem like people care it's like self
dealing instead of inclusive fitness and
it feels like it's because the inclusive
stake holding isn't there well yeah so I
don't have a physician or a teacher or
or a government or a food company that
that has it that has a stake in my
health right and my actualization a
stake that is not just profit driven
right I mean health should be delivered
for health health should be delivered
for money think about what we do we have
as a per for profit so hospitals schools
and prisons how can those things be for
profit or military hah well the whole
idea of a prison for profit the idea
that how do you make profit of prison
you have more people in prison that's
gonna drive a system that incarcerates
more people a health care system where
profit is the I'm not saying you
shouldn't do research and make money off
of new drugs and charge people for
access to health care but the goal
should be to make people healthy make
their lives better rather than to make
extra money I think doctors should be
paid well yeah I think teachers should
be paid well you know why are those two
things like in they don't seem to be
equitable so so but where does all this
come from right why aren't we still all
running around mostly getting along well
throughout our entire history humans do
not run through fields of daisies
holding hands right we've fought we
killed each other we were horrible to
one another but not all the time not
regularly and not with great frequency
because as you said it wouldn't have
worked right if you had a group of
people who were all jerks that you know
that really wouldn't last so what
happened what's back to structures and
hierarchies of inequality how do you
develop radically unequal systems you do
it by other in people you do it by
making someone less than you do by
having a system where they're the haves
and the have-nots and the only way we as
humans can can live with that
is if we differentiate ourselves
thinking that the others that have less
have less because they're worth less
right and our political and historical
economic structures over the last you
know a couple millennia clearly show
that this is a pattern ER process
especially over the last 500 300 years
and so one could ask these systems that
have emerged over the last 300 500 years
that are horribly unequal and
problematic in many ways it's not the
only way humans can do things they're
not some that the whole contemporary
geopolitical landscape is not a given
it's not the only way humans could have
gone it's not the only way humans can go
right so we're still have this
opportunity to change but but we better
do something quickly if we look around
the world today you know the whole earth
is about to like vomit us out pretty
soon because we're at a you know a
tipping point here and and when I say
we're at a tipping point I'm not an
alarmist we're not going extinct
you know a lot of people we said oh
we're gonna go see no no that the earth
can sustain twice or more as many humans
as there are now but the level of
suffering that humans undergo right now
for me is unacceptable think how much
worse it's gonna be as more humans on
the planet if we don't change how can we
take what story we tell and rather than
making it be about fear which is what
I've seen be so persistent instead we
make it about exploration and prosperity
abundance right all these really cool
words that we want to build the next
world with and architect
and design that fabric think that gets
us there what are those pieces to that
directional arrow that take us to that
future yeah that's a great question and
I wish I knew all the pieces but sort of
is time back to teachers you know
education so knowledge you know people
throw around the phrase knowledge is
power lightly
they shouldn't yeah it really is it is
it is and so understanding basic things
about human biology basic things about
ecology understanding a good and
accurate representation of our history
yeah those things actually make you
aware of patterns and processes that
help you understand where we are today
so if more people actually had a good
idea of like why are things the way they
are more people might I don't know if
they would but might be a inclined to do
something about it and be able to do
something about it right so what the
first thing is knowledge I mean we sort
of in this country it's weird we've
given up sort of on educating children
that's and and and by that I mean we
sent him to school but we sent him to
school to get tested what was you know
school should be about learning social
skills
yeah reading writing math but the
playing learning how to navigate the
landscape making friends fighting with
friends I mean it should be this entire
experience of socialization and
knowledge enhancement and creation you
just talked about sort of you know the
idea of
more of abundance of thinking through
things but what abundance what do we
want to have we want more money better
society right I'm not saying those two
things are mutually exclusive but if
we're training people to succeed at
standardized tests and to go out into
the world and strive for profit in
whatever they do we're cutting out so
much of human capacity and potential and
we're also developing people who are
ignorant to other ways of joy right
other way you talked about abundance
abundance can be measured in many many
many ways there's great research and
this is some of my favorite stuff that
that you look at sort of older men in
the United States you know what the top
indicator of longevity and happiness is
it's not wealth it's not even what they
did as a job in their life it might not
even be whether or not they had a family
it's how many individuals late in life
they identify as friends it's how robust
their social network is yeah don't you
tell us something right shouldn't that
tell us something it should say look at
that this social network stuff
connectivity for better and worse it's
sort of what we do so we better pay more
attention to it because if you have 710
really strong friends that you hang out
with that you can count on that that in
your later parts of life are just these
really close nodes that you're connected
to it those spokes versus what we see
and sometimes today when people are
young people are asked the question you
know how many people would you call a
close friend that you could call in the
case of an emergency or to talk to about
something that's very vulnerable about
what is going on with you all that's one
of the reasons why we have that mental
health issues absolutely interesting so
that's the number one it's a bunch of
studies so it's one of the top ones and
it correlates with health outcomes
health outcomes right and that's also
similar with all these they're called
Blue Zones life's an absolutely at so
you go around the world there's this is
it I think is my partner Davey Snively
hip
to this term it's a Japanese tournament
it's called iki guy hmm
and and I think if I might be
misrepresented but it's generally to
paraphrase it it serve this notion of a
purpose yeah right having something that
your life is not just about living it's
about doing yeah it's about being with
and and and you know people who are in
their lives who enjoy or at least have
this thing that they do they live longer
so you gotta ask yourself what is it
it's health is not just a biological
assessment health is literally a state
of mind as well yeah yeah making one of
the parts of that directional arrow be
the architecting of that social fabric
where every single child when they're
born into the world can have their
fullest potential to achieve what
they're uniquely gifted for and
blueprinted to do in this world so that
they can roar with that fire every
moment of every day
is so massive it and that whole thing in
the I'm actually push on one thing go
please yes yes I wouldn't say we're
blueprinted all right because that that
I understand what you mean but but that
almost limits because it's not humans
can do anything right we're all quite
distinctive in our patterns and our
physiological capacities and even our
neurobiological capacities there's a lot
of variation but how we actually map
across the space of our life history
it's not so much a blueprint but a
dynamic interface instead we got a
discovery process yeah yeah yeah and so
okay so how do we facilitate flourishing
right which is what you arguing here you
know how do we facilitate this dynamic
process so this this is this being can
vacillate across opportunities
fulfilling and flourishing what that
that biological that original that
potential is right it's not one thing
it's a whole bunch of different
possibilities and if we're open to that
and we don't believe that there's only
one successful way to be human there's
not there are many good flourishing so
yes could you argue that then
when one finds themselves with that
process of the dynamic interfacing of
identifying what this may be North Star
or North Stars are and that were fueled
by that fire every day that then could
we not also look back and let's say if
we find that out when we're 30 and we're
roaring what they could we then say that
maybe I was uniquely you know
blueprinted with that this and I found
sure so there is that I love that
conversational point because it's just
it's the every single one of us has a
passion for bringing a gift into that
world yeah what absolutely and we don't
know but we frequently don't know what
that is right and that's why in school
like when I'm talking to undergraduate
students when they're going through
their you know university degree they're
like oh I need a major I have to focus
right away I'm like fine you know I'm
sure your parents they're pushing you
and your advisors are but you know take
some fun classes to figure out what's
out there this is a university right you
get four years you're lucky enough
you're amongst the most privileged
individual on the planet
you get four years to like figure out
like what kinds of knowledge you want to
dabble in and we can even go potentially
more efficient although the brain is
less developed by the by 18 when you're
indicating that they take the four years
but just we can expose children to such
a myriad of different plays and and
experiences that then they themselves in
meetups and all these different ways for
them to figure out what they're
passionate about as well and kids can do
it right I mean if you stick a child in
a multilingual environment right and do
not instruct them yeah they can pick up
four or five languages by the time
they're 12 you know that's because it's
the BRIT I mean humans are just like
gimme I need I want knowledge I want
experience I want and so this when we
talk about flourishing part of that is
just providing the opportunities and
this is back to where inequality is so
damaging where people feel separate and
alone when we take away and take away
and take away those possibilities of
flourishing for children we see the
downstream damage
exactly yeah it also is a that process
of flourishing for every new seed is
that we've been looking at it a lot like
a big tree of possibility in that over
over time we want to accomplish as much
of our unique gifts
preferably you know to understand that
by twenty or thirty rather than diets
yeah yeah yeah not know what it even was
and and then but even proceed right the
see tonight but that precede area is you
know your your family's ancestral
lineage like did they have significant
trauma where dude when you were born did
you get love like get air food water
shelter because if any of those roots to
the tree didn't were traumatize didn't
have the nutrients the seed isn't gonna
produce as a bountiful amount of fruits
then it can then share with each family
friends the civilization at large yeah
absolutely yeah that's a perfect sort of
way to describe this and back to our
notion of ecosystems right why is that a
perfect way because this is true for all
life why should humans be any different
right and so that was beautiful right
because I think you know those that that
capacity to reach branches into the sky
and flower right it's really dependent
not just on the individual but on
everything around that individual and on
the history of that individual and that
individuals path before that individuals
even born so that's what scares me about
where we are right now is that most
people don't think about this and most
people don't recognize how important
each life is in this way how we are one
and how these dynamic processes connect
us all together
therefore it is our responsibility every
one of us but especially as we said
earlier some have more power than others
so those with power they
right so we in the United States should
be leading not destroying right I mean
where where there's a concentration of
capacity we should be deploying that in
ways that augment the possibilities of
flourishing yes not restrict them yes
this is this is the ultimate you we just
gave that this this analogy just how do
we make it so that those seeds that are
born have all of those nutrients and
their roots that they need and then can
produce identifying produce the fruits
that they you nee CLE can gift into into
our world and and the leaders like you
said a better leading in the economics
you know this is such a thing you put a
hierarchy up and then it automatically
go to wealth right at the top and then
we always counter that by saying what if
it was the most enlightening at the top
what if you threw that Dalai Lama and
all these other spiritual elders at the
top because where do these 1500
billionaires even fit right what if n
none of them have would have very few of
them like maybe only 10% of them have
ever even felt Eagle loss before and
feelings of interconnectedness around
conditional love then we're really
talking like how do we get to the other
90% and catalyze these feelings of
interconnectedness and Eagle cause
that's the hierarchy based on spiritual
enlightenment and then see where people
yeah I mean there's so many ways we
could do this it is not a given right
we just most people just throw their
hands up and or they don't even throw
their hands up they just follow and
that's a problem right
IIIi would like to see people this is
horrible because I don't think anger is
the right solution but I would like for
now just a little bit I'd like to see
people get a little angry I would like
to see people be upset that the
potential of all these seeds the soil in
which we are sowing our seeds the world
into that were poisoning it I cried on
an episode about six months ago or so
when I cried about the exact thing that
you're talking about I started feeling
the seeds of the children that we're not
going to be able to express the
it's uniquely due to the social fabric
and and it's up to us to communicate to
story tell to inspire so that way they
can everybody born can can do so these
are your siblings yeah yeah yeah oh man
that story time that said what are
humans do we're storytellers that's what
we do and and so knowledge is power
right but one of the biggest problems we
have as educators right or the official
you know structure of Education is that
we're frequently not good storytellers
that's horrible we have all this great
now it's like biology and intro biology
class that should be the most dynamic
amazing experience of everyone's life
it's incredible like you took actually
learn how seeds grow right here you did
that great analogy you just so you
walked us through it but the biochemical
the structural all of it it's it's mind
book we couldn't make this stuff up it's
incredible so I mean you know what what
can we do people always asking what can
you do well one thing you can do is is
is learn how to relate to other people
through story if you if you have
knowledge share that knowledge right and
it's what you're doing right you're
trying to say hey look there's a bunch
of knowledge the bunch people have it
why don't we figure out some way to get
it out and and what shocks me is with
all of these democratizing technologies
we have you know the ability to
broadcast in every one of our hands but
people aren't thinking enough about well
how do I broadcast what do I broadcast
and why do i broadcast yes to tell the
stories to inspire yeah to build that
next world yeah we need to ask you this
question as well all of these things
that we've been talking about on this
second round together does it feel like
the unique complexities of this reality
that we find ourselves in and this
rising to this grand challenge of
solving what we've been talking about is
the exact purpose of this being made in
the first place
yeah well I don't know right this is one
of those things where I my world where I
focus right I want to know what what can
I understand and how can I translate
that understanding into a tangible thing
that will facilitate using back to our
metaphor here that the improving the
soil mm-hmm
what's the whole purpose what's going on
that's a great thing to muse about but
I'll be honest I don't have an answer
right but the the capacity to ask the
question to seriously ask the question
to think about it is something we all
need to do and whatever people's answers
right because people of different
answers for why I mean the big why what
am I doing here and what's what's the
purpose and is what I'm doing actually
reflected of us of an actual system out
of trajectory I don't believe we're
locked into one trajectory but I do
believe based on what I know about the
world and ecosystems that you can
predict where things are going we have
the understandings a lot of the systems
and processes and so looking back gives
us some insight to the future yes right
so whether it's all predetermined I
would say I I don't think so
but whether we're on our trajectory we
are but it's it's malleable right we can
we can shove it a little bit this way
and nudge it that way and I think that's
that's the the real hopeful thing that
no matter what so many of us can believe
so many different things about why but
we can actually agree on what and I
think that's really important
it feels like more and more after doing
this show and featuring all these
different leaders especially across
science and spirituality and the
marriage of the two it feels like more
and more that this was all made for this
exact
process that we're going through and it
is profoundly beautiful and being able
to experience it through this vehicle of
a body yeah it's just so majestic good
term I like that it is it is majestic
the he just all of this stuff is
majestic it's nice but it's nice to
remember that right people forget and
people think about the mundane of the
body
I remember the majestic of the
experience yeah yeah and when we when we
are really deeply immersed in the
majestic and the beauty of that were
here going through this process and it
is not something that is just in the
brain intellectualized but it's deeply
embodied and then interconnected with
all of the other millions of species of
the other billions of humans in the
whole biosphere the entire actual
reality that we're in then we feel home
then then know the feeling is there and
then there's then all the other those
issues we were talking about they don't
come up yeah yeah oh wow Alex seen what
a profound second conversation this has
been you know it just it's fun talking
with you just because you know the
opportunity to explore freely this kind
of engagement it's a gift the tennis
ball going back and forth good tennis
players and yeah you know that's and we
stand on the shoulders of all the other
people that exist better tennis bigger
exactly so we have a responsibility so
as we do
I love it thank you so much for coming
on the program for all my pleasure
anytime fun and he's so fun I love it
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
and check out the links in the bio below
to Augustine's work check out the links
below to his books also check out the
links below to the American
Anthropological Association you can go
and support them on Twitter you can go
and check out their website as well
those links are in the bio below also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the organizations
around the world and in your communities
that you believe and support them and
help them flourish you can find our show
simulation all of our links in the bio
blode patreon cryptocurrency paypal like
you design cool merch and get paid all
those links are in the bio below so you
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to have that conferences
interview their leaders and go and build
that future that we were talking about
in this episode manifest your destiny
into the world we love you very much
thanks for tuning in everyone we'll see
you soon awesome Wow
boom what a crazy round two
[Music]
you
[Music]
that's great man so good I realize
you've got yeah I got a run yeah I just
I love chatting with you because as an
interviewer right you have you have just
you you understand narrative flow and
also just I hate the term spiritual
sometimes but just like you we can do
things you know and that's fun because a
lot of people are worried about where
things are going as opposed to trying to
sort of find your time with tennis match
right so we harmonized there playing
tennis tickly yeah that analogy of the
tree of possibility I was easier II play
I've been working on that for a while
and I'm figuring out how to disseminate
it through chimps is one of the ways
that you can do like that I love that
because it's just just even with your
hand the end of the hole that thing and
it was a very short very clear and it
beats seed in the ground the nutrient at
the tree that's part you know I mean
because it's a purpose line that yeah
and it's and it's it's an old I mean
it's something that a lot of people
abused yeah but but you just you you
have a good way I think that set it up
so that it's not you know I'm just lucky
before it's clear this is not just a
plant right yeah but it is a planet you
and remembering that is important yes
yes and it ties us to plants to your
organization is that all this stuff yeah
yeah I love it
you